[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello hello hello and welcome to
the middle of week in between week six
and seven we're practically in heaven
why because the football film vault is
open Sims the doorway with a key saying
come on in let me teach your brain come
on in let me show you my closet where I
watch film I'll edit this out don't
worry that's a bit I'll put a bleep yeah
giving up mice hiding from people in
bleacher oh yes I am over here I don't
want to tell you where the treasures
located but it's not under the table
behind the old desk I know where it is
hey grill shocker you're wearing a
maroon hoody yeah listen man at this
point of the year I'm about consistent
greatness every day I need to be better
than my last I I don't look at the wind
and get soft I don't look at a loss and
get overwhelmed it's a good hour through
a good hoodie John Elway said your soft
brother John Elway it's not allowed to
correct anybody because he hasn't made a
good decision in three years Oh am i
yeah find the light find Ally yeah
what's the lie advanced Joseph was Case
Keenum working out for him Paxton well I
don't blame it all on case Kennedy no
but I mean the leak Jackson a good
decision drafting him how a Chris Harris
- I was not three years ago no but I'm
just I'm saying in the last in the last
few years since the Super Bowl all right
I love how we get into AFC West talk for
the second episode of row without
planning this at all what happened
though the Raiders Thursday yeah but not
talking about the Raiders this week my
my thing what Denver is people keep
thinking that I heard someone talking
about this on the show might have been
Francesa about how Elway settled for
Keenum right no L we signed Keenum
before all the other quarterbacks went
gone remember he signed him before Kirk
Cousins before the Alex Smith thing
happened right he's like I got my guy
Case Keenum
yeah I'm gonna put a little bit on the
feet of Case Keenum yeah I hear you but
when you allow 200 yards rushing I'm not
gonna put it on there and he's got Chad
Kelly as his backup
no but the Vance Joseph thing yes he
does you're right we'll see yeah I mean
I do
Chad's ready to play because the crowd
went nuts when he came in no they did I
texted you like it's Chad Kelly time I
texted you at the same times like chug
go I mean I think he's ready I do I mean
I think he knows that if there's a few
more games like we saw that he's gonna
get a shot I had your breakdown queued
up and ready to go from August hey he
came in took a knee and it was halftime
so I
he's got ability there's no doubt about
any fearless those Artie has Emmanuel
Sanders Demaryius Thomas Cortland Sutton
right Cortland son to the baller yes all
right
oh hey hey chirp chirp chirp chirp chirp
don't even start
don't even start are you the Superbowl
again whether the birds are telling us
we got a bar the Superbowl everything
you want to give any information no just
that the birdies are talking to us Oh
what are the birdies saying Josh birdies
you're saying we might be going to
Atlanta the super what you're going to
Atlanta for the Superbowl and we're
gonna be there all the time during the
week they want to come hang out they
should come hang out and like me and
Josh are sitting in rooms thinking okay
Tuesday night should we bring out a
laptop and have Sims break down the film
and from now ok Wednesday should we like
just do trivia with all the homies that
come out right yeah cuz look on the way
that we're kind of looking at it right
now is we have a job to do we have
players to interview we're gonna do that
all week but we're trying to come up
with stuff that if you guys make the
trip to Atlanta we're gonna hang out
with you and and look I really want to
bring a laptop up there and projector it
up and go okay here's what happened the
AFC Championship game here's what
happened the NFC Championship game
watched film with sin okay that's one
thing we want to do that's cool you like
that I do like that I might not like
pitching you live for the first time I
know thank you yes nothing like putting
me on the spot good old left go style
can I hear a bird sound from you though
do you have a chirp Superboy you want to
talk about it Lana
Simza left go fantasy league got the win
both Aaron Rodgers thank you so now
we're at three and three
Roger and my trade is looking a lot
better with Devonta Freeman going on I
are good job looks like we really dodged
a bullet on that one we want fantasy in
the first quarter it was over throws a
touchdown we were good to go
I really got our status going our
opponent also didn't start someone in
his Flex position and then today though
what was really funny as air Rogers on a
bike damn and Simms has told me that
we're not allowed to play Blake bortles
so I go ok Simms here are the options CJ
bet it's a 14 team lead CJ Beathard
against the Rams Eli against the Falcons
good matchups and he goes Oh neither and
I go no no Sims we have to my place
rather not play someone yes no work his
direct quote was the receiver and then I
said well we could do dak against
Washington and he goes I'd rather lose
and half any of them on our team but I
go no like the point of fantasy is to
win and so he was fine Eli uh-huh damn
which leads me to this point yes I am
not letting Eli come out of here with
any win so he's playing Atlanta on
Monday night yeah Eli should have the
breakout game Monday night this should
be the Eloi game yeah
Odell Beckham should go off all of the
problems are erased it's a 30 to 27
shootout and the the Giants offense is
back and they're coming off a Thursday
night game so they got 11 days to
prepare
Eli is supposed to make me look stupid
this week and put up 300 yards and three
touchdowns there's a good chance he will
so if he does not egg on my face egg on
your face
but if he doesn't now we really it's no
problem
right like if Eli doesn't put up yards
against the Falcons on 11 days rest with
their backs against the wall facing the
worst pass defense in the NFL other than
maybe the Buccaneers but also are coming
up on his schedule right so like Eli
should put together back-to-back great
weeks he should
if he doesn't uh oh yeah you're right
it's at the Falcons Redskins at home by
week 49ers Tampa Bay Buccaneers Oh 49ers
- I know their 25th in the league in
passing so yeah you got issues there
yeah so that's why I'm saying I am
predicting an Eli resurgence and
everyone's gonna be like oh all the
haters see you're an idiot
it's supposed to happen let's get ahead
of this I hope he like calls you out in
the media
that's all I wonder he goes for 400
yards Lisa Salters feel like Eli a lot
of people in the media this is my
least-loved tone I mean he knows he lies
like he's like jay-z he's not gonna get
into petty Rap Battles to somebody like
you man sorry you're like who who was
the one jay-z said he wouldn't get into
the battle with a few years I'm not
gonna [ __ ] help you not gonna help me
do your Lisa Salters impression again I
don't that was tessitura but like it was
like a lion reporters like if Tessa tour
was inside of a tunnel yeah moving on uh
I got some bad news
mmm the bad news that you didn't break
any news the reason you didn't break any
news is Matt Simmons didn't get signed
by the Niners yeah instead they signed
Tom savage however in the press release
that came out right it did say that Matt
Simms impressed the 49ers coaches huh
according to some reporters okay and it
came down to him versus Tom Savage right
and the difference was Tom savage played
last year yeah that's never been getting
Mac can't ever play nobody will give us
a quarterback suppose it's like the
question for like kids out of college
we're looking for someone experienced
how am I supposed to get experience if
I'm never getting a chance I know it's
tough but yeah you know I thought that's
the reality the situation I haven't even
talked to him I didn't really even have
the guts to call him yeah I had a
feeling that if you're listening I love
you and [ __ ] him I had a feeling I had
a feeling it was coming and yeah I
didn't even have the heart I just was
like gosh I just let him find out
himself but I'm sure he's yeah he's I'm
sure he's disappointed he's he's better
than the options in Buffalo he's still
working really hard and doing his best
and keeping the dream alive and we'll
see I mean you know hey people forget
you know people didn't think Rich Gannon
was good until he's about 29 years old
and there's like Rich Gannon wasn't on a
team until he was like 29 how did that
happen because there's a lot of idiots
in the NFL but how did he finally get a
chance he begged the Kansas City Chiefs
and he knew the quarterback coach there
which I can't think of at the time might
have been I don't think it was Paul
Hackett then but he called and begged
and begged and they finally brought him
in to some spring training and things
like that then he impressed them and
made the roster and then he finally got
some chances those stories are always
wild is the Chiefs of the Vikings maybe
I'm a little off on my facts there but
something like that he was uh he was
with the Vikings through the 1992 season
right Wade in Washington in 93 okay and
then didn't play in 94 and then plate
for the Chiefs in 94 there you go so it
was the Chiefs to e that's what I'm
thinking of so he had there and what
year was he in 92 like you say how old
he was 92 I could figure it out give me
a sec yeah do that Matt you're not real
good at math that you're good at a lot
of things
yeah I'm really bad I can add I can't
look at numbers and figure it out fast
seriously I can't add it's unbelievable
I can't quick in his head like when we
do our bets or anything like that he
messes them up are you good at
multiplication tables like when they did
that in elementary school and they do
like a timed thing how'd you finish I
was fine at that cuz that I could
memorize I could go home and be like I
wanna cheater 2 times 2 4 times like a
week multiplication yeah like what's 12
times 11 that I couldn't do in my head
well it would be 144 minus 12 so even
that though took you to us because I
have you got to you got to path let's
take a step back yeah well I'll take an
extra hitch step before I go yeah it's
about the amount Josh's I was bigger
than you earlier oh yeah you probably
were I'm saying my at my early age like
I knew multiplication tables and like
kindergarten and my parents through and
my mom so she's like oh my gosh I have a
really smart kid you know only reason I
was good at multiplication like but this
curse not the big numbers but because
the football I knew if he scored scored
four touchdowns he had 28 points and I
was very so you had worked on set I had
worked
right so I was like oh okay I got this
is multiplication and I remember the
first time my kindergarten teacher went
through things and I was like 24 pull
yeah and they were looking at me and I
was and they were like why are you
yelling her in school what's funny would
have been 27 by 7 yeah that's up there
for a young kid yeah 27 yeah so my
multiplication story is also a lesson of
not everything is great to hold on to
sometimes you should enjoy it in the
moment he would have been 30 sorry there
was 95 books
1995 he would have been 30 so third
grade I had Mrs Brady and every Friday
they give us a multiplication timed and
if you finished in the top three
you got to pick a jolly rancher I want
to tell you I never didn't finish in the
top three I was like like I would like
knock people's pencils I was like I'm
finishing this and what I would do is
I'd only take what Jolly Rancher would
you pick and what Jolly Rancher do you
think I picked all right I would
definitely take cherry I knew you were a
chick yeah and you're definitely a sour
apple guy thousand-person on diversity
what are you I feel like he's a pie
can't believe I got that you're such a
sour apple guy I love so not a huge suck
candy guy I never really had Jolly
Ranchers all right what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you a lot of things clearly I
don't know I just didn't really yeah so
I had a box on my desk and every time I
want a sour up a Jolly Rancher I put it
in that box and I would and I said you
know what I'm gonna save this for the
summer so that when I'm like you've
revived a candy and I left go house I
mean you guys look like you were that
deprived all right chill okay so I never
forget last day of school and everyone's
getting ready to leave and I pop open
the box and I go I'm gonna have one of
these just - and I also wanted to just
stunt on all the other kids in the class
and be like remember all those candies I
won and it was filled like to the brim
like there were big ones and small ones
and all that and I reached in and I saw
a little bit of the tail sticking out
and I went and I grabbed it and I pulled
it and they all came and all 80 of them
came up in one solid block and that's
when I learned you know don't save the
best piece of your food
for the last bite it's gonna be cold
yeah you didn't just chip away I told
the stuff yeah I've heard you tell me
before I've never heard you had sour
apple written all over you to make me
happier after that story
Blake jar win' has one catch and we've
been reached back out to buy the would
rage master about him because he should
have caught that ball the other day in
the game and so we are on pace to one of
the amazing Sims and left go faithful
shaving his eyebrows for the podcast
send us a picture of his face with both
eyebrows great but so they're still
there okay and that's probably what we
should probably make sure we can get him
to Atlanta and have him do that there Oh
a little birdie told me we should go
birdie can't be paying for people to fly
Lana you're there and probably do it
live would be amazing so Bill Belichick
was at the podium today yeah and
someone's like you're playing Kaleo Mac
and you know you coached Lawrence Taylor
and and you know he was pretty darn
amazing and you know what do you think
of comparing the two and and he said so
bail bill says I'm up with anybody
Lawrence Taylor's this guy man and I
love that yeah
so first what does that make you think
well that's his guy like I said I mean
there's no Bill Belichick without the
unleashing of Lawrence Taylor right I
mean that's how part of who bill became
is because he had this three-four
defense and they had this freaky outside
linebacker that changed the game of
football as we know it first
can you compare Khalil Mack and Lawrence
Taylor are they a little bit closer than
he's saying
um yeah they're a little closer than
they're saying I think the big thing is
he's saying is Lawrence Taylor was 30
years ahead of his time right there's
like there was nobody in football like
Lawrence Taylor Lawrence Taylor has the
same size as the Khalil
Mack but thirty years ago and he's
faster than Khalil Mack
there's no Donati vain' close December
31st 2014
Bill Belichick compared Jamie Collins to
Lawrence Taylor August 4th 2015
Belichick said Willie McGinest like
Lawrence Taylor was smart tough but
always an extra the tanking critical
situation ok the 79 Lawrence 2015
Belichick compares JJ Watt to Lt quote
he's pretty special in the same general
category as LT I do think that we're not
letting Bill Belichick slide on this
yeah yeah I hear you and you know he's
trying to give respect to khalil Maggie
this is the first time they're like -
like a few weeks ago he said that Blake
bortles is like deshaun Watson and Cam
Newton he always builds up the opponent
he this was the first time where he went
no right you're right it is I was kind
of surprised that's the first thing I
thought of that he's like not he usually
goes out of his way to praise the other
guy praise the other team they usually
he doesn't praise people if he really
wants his team to have confidence
against yeah maybe there could be
something there to that I do think you
know he holds Lawrence in a very high
regard I think he I think you know I've
heard him talk about this no he thinks
like that those defenses back in that
day and I think he thinks the upper
echelon of Defense's and because there
was no salary cap there was a lot more
talent concentrated on certain teams
right where it's like the old Celtics
right there was no free like like he
would tell you like you know or the 86
Giants like Lawrence is a hall-of-famer
he thinks Carl banks should be a
hall-of-famer the other outside
linebacker you know Harry Carson is a
middle linebacker hall-of-famer you know
Pepper Johnson like in bills eyes like
those those defenses don't exist anymore
that doesn't exist to have that type of
talent on the field let alone with guys
like Leonard Marshall at d-line who he
looks at is like a Hall of Fame 5
technique defensive tackle I've heard
bill talk about you bill talk about LT
before I can't say that I have I got you
big Phil that's something we should ask
big Phil later on blood your persona I
think the thing that's the biggest thing
there and you have to remember this this
was we
never seen a guy like Lawrence Taylor
come to the NFL dad will tell you he saw
Lawrence Taylor at 6-3 255 run for five
on grass in person so to run that on
grass - that's like redonkulous and you
know you add to that story like - tight
end sets and double-teaming you know
with a tight end than a tackle was
invented in football yes because of
Lawrence Taylor because of Joe Gibbs Joe
Gibbs basically said I give up I'm not
putting my left tackle on Lawrence
Taylor or any more one-on-one we've
talked about this Phil Walsh invented
the athletic left tackle right or the
guard that pulls out to the left or like
it necessitated speed and good feet on
the offensive line because before that
they were all road graders yeah I have a
question for you okay
Broncos Cardinals Thursday night Broncos
are desperate for a win yeah Cardinals
are desperate as a franchise and Von
Miller came out and said this I wouldn't
say it's a must-win all right but we're
gonna kick their ass make sure you put
that up there this week Thursday night
primetime they're gonna get the Broncos
best and he continued this week's
totally different we're gonna go out
there and kick their ass that's the way
I'm feeling yeah we always hear about
bulletin board material yeah one is
there an actual bulletin board there is
so in locker rooms there's a place
that's a bulletin board yeah I mean
thumbtacks some of them did yes or it
could just be a wall yeah they ever they
would might maybe Pais up the articles
are certain clothes so second question
that they would put up articles and
quotes from other teams definitely I
would definitely go on in a lot so when
there's bulletin board material there's
actually a bulletin board that has
material not in every locker room but
the other thing that goes on if it's not
in the locker room like a position coach
is gonna show it somewhere no I like the
offensive lineman figure they put it up
on the screen on his big screen or is
you know what's the thing that takes the
picture and director objector also he
added this too yeah I don't think
there's anybody in the league that can
block
and Bradley chub especially not the
Cardinals ooh
that's that's definitely gonna make the
bulletin board in the offensive line
room so one I've already asked you is
there bulletin board to do they put
material yeah three does it's
fascinating to me right millions of
dollars go to these athletes they know
this is their job they're gonna go out
there they're going to play but could a
quote like this genuinely make people
play harder it's a game that's so close
and the talent levels so close between
the greatest linebacker and the
linebacker who's just a starter and not
that great in our eyes you know that
star that we've elevated onto a pedestal
yeah it's I guess what I'm trying to say
is everybody's looking for their own
little advantage they certainly are but
does this create an advantage do you
think that the Cardinals will play
better because von Miller's comments
pissed them I think that they will pay
attention to little details and little
things like that to go damn I don't want
this guy's you know his what am I saying
he's telling in the future is
Proclamation yes to come true
on TV it's made national news and it be
on me so I do think yes that plays into
a part of it you know again these are
humans they're competitive
I like that Bob Miller did this I think
that some people are gonna say why would
you give the Cardinals a lot of credit
like why would you give them motivation
I think the Broncos need to believe in
exactly they don't care anymore he's two
they're two and four they've been beaten
down the last two weeks yes and he's the
leader of the football team he's the
highest-paid guy the locker room and
this is his job and he's finally putting
you know a flag down in the middle of
their locker room like hey [ __ ] off I'm
not put nine minutes right I'm putting
my name on so you think you spawn my
back and let's go and let's put our best
effort now so you think this emboldened
maybe both team I do I do I think
especially when he says what he said
about those tackles yeah that's gonna
and that will that will also enrage
David Johnson who's gonna go oh you're
gonna talk crap about my dad ship this
shouldn't see that chip I give you in
your kidney later on in the fourth
quarter or it's gonna I'm thrilled
because this was the war
Thursday night matchup maybe of the
season and I'm still gonna watch it cuz
it's my job right and I'm happy that
this has happened that between that and
then didn't Wilkes say I'm like Sunday
night or Monday like he made a comment
like we need to play away we're gonna be
fired if we lose this game yeah so yeah
there's ratios that'll be fun man
Vance Joseph says we're a broken record
I was Elway or broken records grood a
big bulletin board material coach uh
yeah he would if something like that
happened that I can't say that I can
think of a specific event but he would
bring it up in a team meeting to be like
we can't get a little way with this guy
saying this or we got a we got to do
something to show this guy we mean
business or whatever it may be and then
my other question would be did anyone
when you were in PEI in the Patriots
didn't ever talk trash about the
Patriots ever no that's the thing as the
Patriots don't have any Bolton blue no
need for both of the Patriots don't do
any of that I mean you can't even talk
to the the patriot players aren't even
allowed to talk to the other team before
the game the coaches aren't allowed to
talk to the other team I see them
talking to each other in the field yeah
like the patriot players don't do that
you know if you went and watched a
warm-up a pregame warmup you would see
definitely less conversations cross team
going on and a pregame warmup with the
New England Patriots than any other team
I could still remember my first time I I
just remember when I walked out to New
England in 2005 and played them at a
regular season in the pregame warmups I
was like whoa this is all business like
they're there there's no like bill came
over and said hello to me he did yeah
bill came over timeout yeah
so you've are you starting yeah I'm
starting right and you're the starting
quarterback and Bill Belichick and I'm
throwing routes too you know I'm in the
middle of the field and I'm starting to
throw routes to guys on the field I'm
thrown slants and comebacks and doing
all that and he said I could see him of
course I'm looking for Bill Belichick
he's built he's just won three Super
Bowls and I I could see him watching me
warm up so I'm like damn bills watching
me I mean better throw this day I'm
gonna say did you throw difference yes I
was I was ready for my a-game anyways
New England is in the pantheon of places
now yeah I don't care after the history
they have had they're up there the
Lambeau Field whatever it may be
it's become that special and he then I
threw a few and then you know you let
your backup throw a few whatever and I
walked her and he came up to me and it
was just like hey it's good to see you
I'm proud of you you know you're playing
great it's been a long time it's been a
long time I hope you're good good luck
today and then walked away yeah that was
it that was it and then I got my ass
beat I mean that was bad that was purple
balls game that was when Vince Wilfork
hit you right yeah I mean that was the
game you need to go back and watch that
just to get enjoyment if you want to
like be like man I thought you wanted
aims right yeah like let me watch
somebody else kicked it because Richard
Seymour hit me up overtime that game and
you know part of the reason I lost my
spleen is cuz I thought I was like you
know you play like Kirsten wins I
thought I was I thought I was Captain
America and I'm just gonna be like god I
just grew didn't used to call me big
soldier
hey don't big soldier cuz he knew I
didn't give a [ __ ] I was like yeah I'm
gonna he's open I'm gonna throw it I
don't give a [ __ ] who hits me brings
that ye life frustrates you so much of
course because that's great quarterbacks
don't do that like Tom Brady doesn't do
that he's in here he's a forty one he's
still doing the same crap but I its
Richard Seymour hit me so flush a few
times in those games and Richards team
were is in that women's Caillat is
Campbell Julius Peppers like holy crap
this is Richard Seymour like he hit
early and I swear I was doing like
figure skating sideways like rolls in
the air like and I would I would throw a
ball and I beg damn I threw that ball
over there in the corner of the room and
I'm on the other corner of the room now
like he killed me we should get this
game film you need to look at it's the
only game ever that I swear that I ever
played we're in the fourth quarter I was
going I'm sore already like I usually
don't happen to the next morning but I
was going damn I'm sore and cuz I took
some big hits and again New England is
always bigger than people realize yes
like I've told you yeah we always think
their jerseys make them look smaller not
Dante Hightower is six for 270 you know
people think it's like he's a 230 pound
linebacker which is incredible because
Gronk looks enormous on that jury he
does look enormous he's that the
tallness sticks out on him first
I guess it's that position to cuz he has
safeties covering him so you get to see
the difference there what was the point
of this story
Bella check talking to you bulletin
board material oh yes right but no New
England was never into bulletin board
material never in today's poll a
Chipotle Burpee I hate like 20 minutes
ago sorry lost 2800 so yeah what did it
was a closer twenty-eight oh then
typical Patriots we were 21 430 455
yards no touchdowns off picks so picks
though rushed rushed once for negative
one yards and you fumble twice
oh I did that was the biggest play of
the game oh the fumble so first of all I
would like to play some blame I'm Joey
Galloway he'd Robbie dropped like the
three biggest passes the game sorry Joey
then went into the bus there it's 12 13
years later you can deal with it
so that was big I grade it out as
playing a really good football game I
mean I was enough I was obviously yeah
yeah I was obviously under duress but
that was the biggest play the game was I
believe like 13 nothing maybe it was
seven nothing at the end of the first
quarter right and then it was 21 nothing
at halftime
yeah they score two touchdowns we kept
moving into field goal position of that
gets sacked and we had a punt we pinned
them down and we did all that so it's 14
nothing and it's we're going on a
two-minute drive at the end of the first
half and I'm going you're fumbles with
52 seconds and we got him we got him
it's like you mean I mean that I know
what blitz they're bringing and we had a
play all week for this blitz and we're
gonna get him play and brontosaurus my
right tackle can Jana Walker we called
the brought to Saurus he was more money
little brain we call them brontosaurus
and Len but we had a bang our call
it's called Bangor which meant he had a
bump out to the next guy which was
Willie McGuinness in this case he'd push
this guy but extend here to go out there
we were gonna basically move that whole
right side of the offensive line go one
guy out cuz we know what blitz they're
breaking the right guard pick
you get the guy exactly right and he
didn't get the check and I drop back and
I got Michael we got we're gonna screw I
think it was Tedy Bruschi one-on-one
with Michael Pittman like smile like go
right up the field on him like he thinks
we're gonna run on the option route and
it's gonna be him and nobody in the
middle of the field and I'm like oh this
is awesome he's wide fumble they pick it
up run it for a touchdown
yeah hit you they were in the back there
minute to like to what the 10 well yeah
Brady ran three plays and then David
Givens caught the touchdown they
shredded our Tampa - that day I know
that who hit you although I think it was
Willie McGinest
mm pretty sure what's it like getting
hit by him boom there they're like again
one of those teams like when I walked
out on the field their roads no okay
just giant mess two giant men giants
they were giant yeah that's where I was
like you know again I've told this story
a lot worse worst Tedy Bruschi in the
all-time linebackers I mean I don't
think he's an all-time great he's a
Patriots legend he has an awesome player
on a you know a really good team I don't
think anybody would go like he's top 20
all-time or anything like that man no
but he was - such a face for they had
such a beat on us left ko which they did
even against Kansas City the other night
where there was a few times where we had
the right protection and we thought the
Blitz was coming this way and just soon
as I said I was getting blue 85 blue
laser laser we got it all picked up blue
85 set as soon as I just said be getting
ready to say said Hut they swear they
backed out and brought the Blitz the
other side and it was a teaching moment
for us because we yeah look I think of
it like this and I'm gonna get to the
next topic here but I remember when I
covered Louisville when they won the
national championship and the thing that
they did that messed everybody up was
they played one defense at a 35 second
shot clock and then at 10 seconds they
switched any different defense right I
remember that and I would just I would
laugh because I'd be sitting there front
row going
watch the watch them [ __ ] their pants
because either playing a matchup zone
that have certain principles and they're
finding the lanes and then that 10 would
hit in your face man a man right and
that's the way I look at the Patriots
defense it's a CH
show you something and then completely
change it up exactly and it could be
that simple speaking of changing it up
should the Cowboys trade for Amory
Cooper oh I do think the Raiders to
trade Mario Cooper I think it's done
there do you think that people should
trade for Amari Cooper yeah but I would
say buyer beware I don't know what Amari
Cooper is right now and you know I was a
huge Amari Cooper fan comment she's not
but yeah um you know I thought there was
a lot of special things about him but
are you noticing stuff on the game film
like what are you noticing about the way
that they use them because sometimes
that you can see it playing yeah they're
not trying to feature ID no they're not
trying to feature it I would argue that
they try to feature martavis Bryant a
hair more than they do him now he's
stolen some first read of certain plays
and things like that and one of the
first passes of the game the other night
he caught a deep cross but it the
Raiders had a holding penalty he gets
called back he's still a part of the
offense but yeah I mean I just think
over the inconsistencies of the last two
years some of the drops some of the
moments of disappearing within the
offense itself
I just know Jon Gruden I know that's
gonna frustrate him I'll let alone a guy
that I feel like he probably could not
make a personal connection exactly right
I don't think he can and I think that's
a flaw that's gonna scare coaches about
Amari Cooper Omar it's all cool and
stuff to act like Amari Cooper does when
you're the man and you're catching a
hundred balls like he did the first year
and he went for a thousand yards and
then the second year was really special
too but as soon as that falls off and
you're acting like that guy no one knows
how to read you no one knows if you're
taking the coaching the communication he
has a weird way we've seen it and so
here we're getting here Josh right as a
wide receiver he can't be too loud
and you can't be too quiet yep you gotta
be just right in the middle so I don't
know what I would say but the Cowboys
there I know they certainly need it I do
know that if it was for the right price
I would take the chance for the right
price I would say like a fourth rounder
and there's no way the Raiders are
taking a fourth probably not I'm not
giving him a first I don't think I'm
giving him a second there's too many
unknowns about it ma Riku
this poor a cooper is the Kawhi Leonard
of the NFL yeah except he didn't have
the MVP campaign and he's not on any
all-nba team all NFL team right but
other than that other than that there's
potential there and I wouldn't be
shocked if he went somewhere and all
sudden we said damn he's he's a new guy
do you think it's a little bit like
Kawhi Leonard where maybe he's best
being a number three on a team and not
having the pressure of being the guy he
could be he could be that type of
demeanor type of guy that maybe he can't
handle I don't think so though I think
he wants to be the guy I think you need
to make him the guy and make him really
feel that way and go out of your way to
a talent still there
it's still good I don't think he's quite
as explosive as he was the first two
years maybe I don't understand what's
happening I don't know either I don't
know what to tell you what just while
that three years ago was Derek Carr
Khalil Mack and Amari Cooper for the
next decade and right now it's kind of
Derek Carr that was a I mean he can't
even do anything that was a dumpster
fire of a game I mean I only watched the
offensive side of the film if you want
to just talk about that real quick I
mean that was that was like fear for
your life Derek Carr the Raiders off his
a lion is atrocious when now oh semele
not in there at left guard and our man
Brandon Parker at right tackle who has
some potential but they were in over
their head to an extent that was I
thought I would not see a bigger
ass-whooping than the Ravens on the
Titans the biggest ass-whooping on the
weekend offensive defensive line matchup
was the Seattle Seahawks whooping the
crap out of the race so the Ravens sect
mariota 11 times right and you're
telling me that Seattle's d-line beat up
the Raiders o-line worse I think so yeah
it was like it was a free-for-all
every place hole Frank Clarke was in
there all the time they aw it was like a
party at Derek Carr let's meet there and
we'll talk about it later
I mean it was every play they had no
chance run game the same the Seattle
Seahawks are intriguing cuz there's two
things going on we talked about their
run game last week how it's legit and
you saw again they dominated in the run
game once again with a stable of running
backs but I think the thing that's
to me is like some of these young
unknowns are starting to show what their
talent is the Seattle you know again
whoo-hoo well I'll get to you in a
second I'll tell you who but like you
know like I'll say this even like the
German James remar we're gonna talk
about it but sometimes when you're young
and you're thinking a lot you can't let
your true ability come to the top yet
because you're thinking and you just
can't go like I'm gonna fly over here
and make the tackle or do this cuz
you're going man coach told me to do
this gap and then do this kind of move
with my hands and it has to kind of
become not a thought before you can
really unleash your ability so guys like
I mean you know Nazir Jones who was good
last year yes he's phenomenal still um
the Brandon Jackson kid at a Texas Tech
number 93 for their football team been
in the rotation but now he's he's met
he's made plays and games the last three
weeks in a row where I go damn this kid
is like he's a player this is not just
like hey we're trying to spell our guys
for five minutes um big poni from Texas
you like poni pune fort poni ford yeah
pull up Ford's ballin really I mean he's
a big poni he was a big ball of Pune
it's unbelievable and he's six
what is Munna he's six foot 305 Wow but
he's a good athlete he's immovable and
when he gets off a block and has to
chase a derrick karr whatever like Derek
Carr was like damn I'm not running away
from this guy him you know Shamar Steven
I'm not saying he's one of the young
guys Ron Reed jaren Reed is good yes so
Frank Clark is right Clark is a real
stud and he dominated in this game and a
lot of plays but yeah those guys right
there anymore impress for Seattle or
more disappointed with the Raiders I
guess more just disappointed with the
Raiders I guess that was a they had no
chance in that game they looked like and
again I didn't know why they were a
little lock were they Seattle is good
job what you're lying
no they were okay but like for me taking
credit about left go Locke's absurd well
you went to Virgil right to it to you
yeah isn't that good yeah if a guy gave
you two locks a week I went to add - I
understand but yes
still gave two locks I mean it no [ __ ]
did you become like like the teller of
the future like this is like really
actually feel this is good yeah keep
mean 2 & 2 I was like if people got 2 &
2 & then you go okay
he gave me 4 games and I know two of
them are gonna be right let me see if I
can listen and dig through some
information and maybe do some of my own
thought here and I'll figure out which
to make the sense can you imagine if
Sims was a character in the Bleacher
Report Instagram comments I wish
everyone is rushing you and then he just
comes in he's like guys cut him some
slack he went 2 & 2 I want him to be
like Clippy that night that 19 Microsoft
95 it's also like you write like a
negative comment like screw you left go
and like Sims pup so it's like hey
[ __ ] do your own homework research
Pig feels good for five o'clock nice
Seattle has the bye and then they go to
Detroit home against the Chargers to the
Rams and then home against Green Bay the
biggest thing for them is the rims I
mean yeah to lose that like they need to
fight for their own division but I don't
think they can come back ya know they're
not gonna win the division yes they're
not getting that either so we'll see
they're not out of that why are you
saying they're not gonna get that um
because I think that they're not gonna
have a better record than the Saints or
the Panthers I only their have a better
record than the Vikings Packers or Bears
well I think the Saints right now we're
gonna be the number two seed I mean yeah
right so so I wouldn't if I were the
first Bears all those type of team
Panthers Bears Vikings Packers whatever
doesn't win the north all right that's
cool they get to play the Vikings and
the Panthers so that's what's cool here
where are those games they are at
Carolina and they're home against
Minnesota they also play Green Bay at
home so be interesting and you know yeah
well say there are definitely an
intriguing team to me right now
especially yes they're turning the
corner which is really cool
and I think that we bagged on them
before but I got we got to give him a
little credit credit we got to give a
credit to John Schneider he's built he's
building back this team it's going in
the right direction and Pete Carroll for
having the wherewithal to get rid of a
Darrell Bevell and go with the new
attitude on the offensive side of the
ball that's not gonna get this high on
the Seahawks I just played
Oakland Raiders in London I'd like I
yeah yeah I understand something else
another weird question so we did
bulletin board material should you trade
Amari Cooper a Khalil Mac all that stuff
people have been noticing that on Monday
Night Football where Aaron frickin
Rogers LED back a comeback after al
Shanahan diced up Mike Patton's defense
yeah like it was Swiss cheese with CJ
Beathard and Rahim most hurt right that
when Aaron Rodgers and the Packers had a
timeout yeah Aaron didn't go to the
sidelines right Aaron stayed in the
middle of the field right I know it's
not as weird as everybody thinks thank
you what's going on because I need
answer I think there's more and more it
goes on more than people would realize I
think if they just took notice to it a
little bit more because a lot of the
times like I know I had moments where
Gruden might have just and I can't just
stay out there don't even don't waste
your energy to stay in the huddle talk
to the guys you know I'll come to you
with a few plays here in a second you
give me a thumbs up if you like one of
them okay cool Aaron Rodgers I think
with this knee you have to take that
into a crouch you might just be nice
stay there don't even walk over here
just leaves off to the sidelines is it
coaches are weird no I don't know if
they're like that but he's just like
take a load off stay over there and you
could do the whole conversation over
there anyways really I mean he can look
over he can tell hey do you like 72 Z
bingo you split and and Rogers can look
at Messiah and give a thumbs up or got
it or if he goes hey how about 200 jet
smoke here and Rodgers might just go
yeah forget about it I don't I don't
like that one can't talk but he's
getting what he can do it and that's
that's really all that situation is it's
not like Rogers is like hey coach I
think we should change the dynamics of
the protection you know what I mean
there no it's not as an in-depth
conversation as maybe it looks like on
TV when everybody's standing there in
the huddle on the sidelines like the
quarterback just sitting there the
offensive coordinator and head coach are
talking to each other he's listening he
might throw in two cents like I like
this play or whatever but I think in
that relationship to that they I'm sure
on a Friday or a Saturday Rodgers and
McCarthy sit down and go through each
personnel set okay
and probably the five favorite plays
Aaron likes and each of the
sets right iboot bet you that's what
happens I know that's it's a West Coast
thing I know I used to do it with Gruden
he'd be like list them for me what's
your what's one for you when I get in
trips right on out of third and ten
third and long
what's your favorite in my third in long
play so he already knows and I would go
you know what I really like 72 all go
special alert clap this week coach I
just think we're not gonna be wrong on
this one that's my number one and win
for you though is it from film study
that you think it's gonna work is it the
route combination that you were just
throwing it better in practice right
well it's a little of all that left go
like he of course is leading the film
study charge is the head coach yeah and
so he's come up with his ten favorite
play he's going that when we do a bunch
to the right typically play this type of
defects after have these routes to take
advantage right and then you get to run
these plays during the week and of
course you're watching your own film and
yeah it's about your comfort level with
whoever may be running some of these
routes your comfort level with the play
for whatever reason some plays just make
more sense to you in your brain just
like anything else I don't you know yeah
I don't know what else to compare it to
people can't do multiplication tables
others can exactly right you know hey
coach when you do this combination I
just I see the field clearly every time
I don't know what it is but when we do
that combination it's just a little
dicey and cloudy to me I don't feel
comfortable about it so those are the
things you talk about on a Friday or
Saturday with your head coach this is
another basketball thing where I think
when you watch timeouts during
basketball games and you see Popovich
there with the whiteboard and he's like
scribbling like crazy and all the
players are looking super intense yeah
that's just not what a football timeout
is no no I was gonna say and you think
it's intense and then they go let's go
the audio of Popovich and he's like play
hard way rebound and I'm always
underwhelmed where it's like this is the
moment right play hard yeah what does
say the same thing know those moments in
the NFL where the whiteboard and stuff
arm when you were truly off the field
half-time like or even like like the
defense came off the field now the
offense out there you know the defensive
line coach might be like hey when they
get in this set we can't let this guard
reach the three technique three ticking
okay we're gonna change this up I want
you to bump out a hair farther in this
formation and then linebacker when you
see him do that you got to come in a
little bit and so those are adjustments
I always wonder I when a game plan goes
to [ __ ] immediate low right and it's
like 14 nothing yeah and everything that
you worked for all week is just up in
smoke right what's happening in those
zones yeah those moments are they're
intense because you're looking at the
coaches and going you don't have answers
and they're looking at you going what
are you seeing yeah right I had him one
of those moments too Arizona Cardinals
28-nothing Patriots okay a lot of these
moments apparently but no 2004 end of
the season Emmitt Smith's last game as
an NFL football player right we're gonna
play the Arizona Cardinals Gruden thinks
he's got a beep on them when they put
this guy over here this is what they're
doing and we're watching film all week
and I'm like Danny's right here right
well they self scouted and they realized
that it wasn't right and so the first
time you see him over there and your
guys are going ha ha ha
you ready scored touchdown it was like
it was it had something to do with the
linebackers on the end of the line of
scrimmage so if he's on this side of the
line of scrimmage you know we're gonna
call the protection this way well the
first 10 plays of the game both their
linebackers got on the line of scrimmage
and we had this whole game plan set up
to go against this little scheme and I'm
literally underneath the center like
looking over at a girdle like I don't
know what to do we didn't you didn't
coach me on this I only can do without
coaching you know and yes that's when it
goes out in the show what happen that's
what goes out the door you go decide
back into let's get into the things we
know we do well we can do the things
that we know we know how to execute and
we can just communicate them at the line
of scrimmage we're gonna get rid of our
little you know intricate plays that we
put in specifically for this game plan
this week let's just kind of go back to
our knees pack our base package that we
always have in and things that you're
comfortable with if they get in some
weird looks that you can figure it out
and get the protection right and all
that but how did that specific one go
like do you go back to the sideline
you're like oh hell that's yeah like
that's what I want and then Gruden like
no Gruden's him he's emotional in like
not like guy
not what do I want to say he's not even
realistic at that time he's still
blaming me even though he knows he's
[ __ ] up the whole week of coaching
he's just gonna be like what are you
doing out there and I'm like they're
both on the line of scrimmage
we talked oh you said one of them we're
gonna be I mean the [ __ ] do some
dinner I'm swearing a lot I think I
better watch it yeah but at the same
point that's not what we're talking
that's the way we were talking and
that's how intensity gets you know that
I've that you know that that was a
special special helmet Emmitt Smith's
last game game where I missed the throat
- Ernest Graham from Florida we're
making you relive a lot of bad memories
right there's been a lot of applications
though to the current NFL's yeah yeah
Ernest Graham Florida running back gosh
we had this perfect play where Gruden
prepared us again all week if Adrian
Wilson's right here pagers yeah he was a
man he was if Adrian Wilson's right here
this is the Blitz that's coming and I
want you to check to this and I'd been
waiting all game and it's like three
minutes left in the fourth quarter and
I'm like I'm going to win the game and
save the day right here and I drop back
and Ernest Graham was open and I'm going
to get hit and I know it and I threw the
ball and I said oh my gosh it's gonna be
a touchdown I threw it perfect and I hit
the ground and my face was in the grass
and I said where the hell is the crowd
and I don't hear anybody cheering or
anything I hear nothing and I looked up
and like everyone was like and I'm like
did I miss that throw I just couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe it was
like where was the ball I threw it like
four feet in front of him I let him a
little too much I got too excited I
don't know what it was but usually as a
quarterback and I think most
quarterbacks would say this and those
type of situations before the ball is
even completed you know when he left
your hand you go that's on the money and
that was like one of two or three times
in my whole life that I threw a ball and
I just couldn't wait to the old linemen
to pick me up like you throw touchdown
and nobody gave
and I was like what the hell happened
yeah and that was a heartbreaker damn
yeah I had when I throw something in the
trash from across the room I'm soon as
it leaves a mask sock in the laundry
basket I'm like but boy you know the
feeling though like just thing is
shooting the basket course right you
know you shoot that ball you go okay I'm
in that left my hand good that's going
on you know and then every now and one
that boots off the back of the room
you're like what yeah perfect and then I
would argue even a better feeling is
when you shooting you go off and then
it's swish you're like oh man I just
don't know all right film 49ers Packers
Monday night game we had to watch it was
our Super Bowl and the first thing I'm
noticing here in your notes is Kyle is
awesome Patton is trying everything yes
so just before we you go into the film
an overarching statement what Kyle did
to Patton yeah take me through what you
think Kyle's philosophy was and then how
do you think peten was reacting when he
was seeing all oh gosh he just took
advantage of some of the aggressive
nature of what Patton does is the line
of scrimmage to stop the run game all of
that as you do well some of the boots
and the play-action passes you saw early
on in the football game I mean you know
Patton's a34 scheme first of all where
it's very hard to play that three-four
scheme sometimes against that that zone
read yeah or not the outside zone type
offense but between taking advantage of
some of that aggressiveness along with
like plays where Green Bay sitting there
they're gonna pass off crossers right
and okay we're gonna pass off the
crossers and the crosser just stop right
there and all sudden the guys that are
passing out the crosshairs like wait
they're not coming to me let me go get
them and then Kyle had to in cut behind
them to screw them and all sudden
they're doing things like that but
Patton got into a part where yeah in
that first second early third quarter he
didn't know what to do to defend Kyle he
was chant after he saw oh my gosh Kyle's
gashed me like three or four times in
the run game he was trying blitzes he
was trying to go to different fronts you
know it was four down it was three down
three four and did they eventually
settle and
something that worked I think at the end
of the game what they finally did was
they finally told first of all yeah they
told they they told their guys stop
worrying about gaps and everything just
go get the ball carrier and especially
the linebackers the linebackers were so
busy all game like okay it's outside
zone so I want to explain outside zone
to everybody because a lot of people had
questions about what is Kyle's running
offense right why does it work and why
doesn't everybody do yeah because it's
he knows the little details to take it
over the edge everybody tries to do it
but they don't know what they don't know
and Kyle like a bell I need you to
explain it yeah okay so everybody has a
gap on a football defense everybody you
get your a gap your B gap your a gaps
between the center in the guard you know
the B gaps between your garden your
tackle and you're responsible for those
right but let's just say the B gap right
between the guard and the tackle and
let's take our three technique in this
case it would be a Kenny Clark let's say
right okay we're a fletcher cop right
but for this game is Kenny Clark line
right so he lines up right in the beacon
he's right in the B gap and he's going
this is my gap you guys go left I'm
going left right go right go right
come at me between you two people
because this is my area and I'm not
gonna let you win this area between the
Garden the tackle I own this
well Kyle does crap where the left
tackle starts just running out and all
sudden the B gap seven feet big and he
goes damn it's big I better go get in
the middle I better go get in the middle
of that gap and he kind of runs out
there to get in the gap but then as he's
doing that the guard pushes him in the
back he goes hey you're in that gap and
now you're all the way out of it cuz you
tried so hard to get there we made the
gap so big you tried to stop it and now
we pushed you out of the way and there's
this big lane right there in our that's
why Kyle likes the Tevin Coleman type
runners cuz now they're running along
the zone and they go oh my gosh it
opened up let me stick my foot in the
ground and soo-ji to the Breda through
the hole or Mozart whoever it is so
that's what that offense at its base
level does to you as far as the zone
scheme he stretches out the gaps so now
where the guys have to run and cover
these big spaces and then he does little
things off of it to make it even harder
whether that's block you in the back
with certain guys our fake a block and
somebody truck traps the the the
linebacker at the second level however
it may be there's little things he does
what percentage of defenses are about
gap contain I mean all are real good all
are I mean it's it's because what you
were saying about just get up field to
get the ball carrier yeah I remember
when Chip Kelly was trying to do a lot
of stretch right the teams that always
killed the Eagles where the teams that
said we're just gonna go straight
forward yes we're not gonna play this
side to side games you can't do because
yeah and that's why doesn't everyone
just do that well they do because also
can get stuck in some you can get stuck
in certain mental edge or yeah or they
run like all of a sudden they run a
play-action pass and also and you're all
upfield and you know there's an easy
solution right behind it or a screen or
something like that so those are the
dangers of what you do but really what I
think they did at the end of the day is
the Packers just said we're gonna get in
a bear friend okay and linebackers stop
reading stuff if you see a hole just run
into the hole cuz that's where the
running backs gonna go and meet them
there their linebackers from Green Bay
are not very good and that's at least
what they started doing at the end
instead of trying to go like oh we're
we're scooting down the line of
scrimmage you know what happens to with
the linebackers is same thing they're
the middle linebackers in the a game a
gap and everybody's flowing to his right
so he's flowing to the right but then
Kyle calls the cutback block right and
all sudden the backside guard has worked
his way up to him and that's a design
cutback and now he scooted so far to the
right that when trying to come running
left and I'll send the guards there like
a pic in the NBA and he's going oh gosh
they're cutting it back let me boom oh
and all sudden breather cuts back and
you go man he's a great cutback runner
and it's really Kyle's like been like no
read that middle linebacker if he gets
too far we're gonna tell the guard to
pick him on the backside and you're
gonna cut back and run for 20 yards and
so why don't a lot of coaches teach this
cuz it doesn't sound I'm I know it's
more I know yeah right well because it's
a small tree of people who really know
it he's protected what is it is it the
footwork is that the pacing is it the
distance like it is it's the footwork
the technique of the blocking to know
how to do each front whether it's a you
know you know there's different fronts
within a four down
run or there's the little rules within
that and then it's also got Kyle's job
to keep them honest with their stuff
with with the bootlegs and the play
actions but just like we've talked about
with Belichick not sharing his whole
scope of knowledge with everybody on his
own staff right yeah Kyle is the same
way like who was better at coaching the
zone run Kyle Shanahan or Mike Shanin
hmm I mean it's very it's the same I
don't know if you could say one's better
I mean they Mike has definitely unveiled
the tricks who taught mike shanahan um
that's a really good question and I'm
not sure I can answer that I don't I
know I know it started no no I know it's
one of his coaches that really started
it though and I'm just blanking on the
naree Kubiak I was a Gib it's an old
line coach that's around and I just
can't think of his damn name but if you
get it we got a dead moment I'll look it
up and tell you about a good yeah I'm
just looking where he was before and
when he was in Denver forever yeah
Denver LA Raiders right back with the
diner right right so ed into the game
yeah to the Niners make a mistake went
through the deep ball I mean it was
obviously a pick like do you think he
was trying to throw a deep ball or do
you think that's what Kyle wanted
because like I told you I thought Kittel
was open underneath for a first down
well I know and like I watched that play
and we could watch it together right now
you want I don't think he was gonna be
able to throw it to kiddo he was a
little under pressure he was gonna get
hit as he was thrown I don't know if
throwing a 40-yard bomb no but sometimes
then those kind of looks which is the
all-out blitz look where you just know
you have four on four and there's no
middle safety sometimes that's the play
you look for to go hey my inside
leverage he threw the ball fifteen yards
short that's the biggest problem good
ones going to go run by him he's running
by him as we're watching it but you're
even you're leaving he was here to stop
I mean the ball should have been five
yards into the end zone I haven't talked
to Kyle but it looked like on like I
told you on TV he said he said Ethan
throw it like like throw it out there
let him go get it it's like he's good
bunny with the Olympics for track and
field so who's faster marques good
winner tarik hill Tyreke Hill that's
really question no that is a question on
the Internet is it yeah it's not because
you just said
Marcus Goodwin's like an Olympic athlete
yeah in a Tyree killeth 15 decided he
wanted to go win the hundred meter he
would have won it except for maybe Usain
Bolt in this prime like you're telling
me that only Usain Bolt is faster than
Tyree kill I'm just saying that I'd
never say that he's faster than you say
no I just I think there's a class of
people in football that some of these
receivers that have at age of 15 they
just said forget football I'm in a train
a track-and-field and be a 100-yard
sprinter or a 100-meter sprint or like
the Odell Beckham jr. and the Tyree
kills would at least be in the final
heat of the Olympics did Aaron Rodgers
play well he played well but he not play
his best game yeah where are we right
now with air well we're back into the
Aaron has to do everything mode we're
also in - he's getting limited practice
reps and I think I wrote in my notes
somewhere even he needs practice right
did you go through my notes yes okay
yeah even he even need he needs practice
there was a few throws that I thought he
was just a hair off on but yes there was
a few moments where he took some sacks
where I said men there was a guy there's
an end cut open over there just throw it
but you know I don't think he is totally
on his a game but his B game is better
than everybody else's ain't game people
were saying that we're making too much
of Aaron Rodgers against a one win
Niners team coming back and winning yeah
I mean the 49ers were the better team on
the field if everybody wants to think
that if you go through the team's
position for position again this is
where the G on the helmet and number 12
at quarterback has is playing tricks on
your brain let's go through it right
left go cuz you and I have done this
offensive line Niners right running
backs Niners
okay receivers III go Packers
right even the Packers Group D on the
field the other night cuz that's the
that's when they were playing there yeah
the hardest thing was judging Packers
receivers is like Rodgers makes wince
Wilson Valdez Spalding look like or they
also have great names Greg what equi
mania st. Browne and Wilson Valdez
Spaulding okay so I give them the edge
okay the other night I think it's very
close okay but if you want to say George
Kittles better than Jimmy Graham he is
definitely better than Jimmy
right now I'm sorry pensive line I'd
probably go Niners definitely
linebackers I probably go Niners right
secondary I go pack yeah okay I got I
feel you they take her I'd go Niners
yeah and putter I don't know yeah and
coach you go Niners
right um yeah I would too so there you
go so again the G on the helmet and
number 12 a quarterback has everybody
going into that game going they're gonna
win no problem nine and a half points
spread and it's an Aaron Rodgers team
that he's not at his best
the team's injured a little bit and beat
up in some key areas and I do put a lot
of the stock into what he did and San
Francisco did some really creative stuff
on the defensive side of the ball they
messed with Green Bay's protections
big-time Green Bay I've never seen so
many free runners coming out of Rogers
they couldn't they couldn't figure it
out so yeah what do you think is silly
or Salah that Roberts Allah I think
defensive coordinator I think he's I I
think he's a good defensive coordinator
I do I don't look at their defense ago
like oh wow they're really they're
really screwing things up no they don't
have like like you said the most
talented secondary in football what's
their overall rank on defense right now
I got it right here
they were like middle of the pack going
under we get their 19th and football
right well this is a theme cuz I want to
move to the Browns
Chargers game yeah and the reason is it
sounds like Roberts a lay right I need
to learn how to pronounce lay is came
from the cover three press bail yeah but
is altering a little bit right the first
thing I noticed from your notes about
Chargers Browns yeah good [ __ ] Gus yeah
you changed your defense yeah so we're
looking at three safeties right now
three six what are the big changes what
did the Chargers do that you wrote they
got it going right now well their
defense he's and that the fact that
they're fast on all three levels exactly
right that's the best the first thing
another team was sneaky good D lineman
and depth even without their best e
lineman or Allegiant being back has to
be big right Cory Legion being back
Darius pylons very good you know the kid
from Notre Dame
Isaac Rochelle yes on the outside he's a
good player
of course we got in melvin ingram guys
like Justin Jones from North Carolina
State another North Carolina state D
lineman he does really well but yes
Gus's yeah what did you change she's
changing up personnel sets he's changing
the looks of their coverages every now
it's not just like the same look same
thing every time and my favorite thing
of what he did is they were playing
three and four safeties at Sunday there
was some obvious because I'd like to
reinforce safe today and and the
smartest thing to do in football I
thought of you when they got too obvious
passing situations they took them there
was no linebacker on the field if I went
out a linebacker right it was four down
linemen and it was
gelila died Derwin james texas hook em
horns
Adrian Phillips and the kid ray Sean
Jenkins from Miami
those are the four guys in the field and
Phillips and Rayshawn Jenkins were
basically playing like middle linebacker
but when they did play the Seattle
scheme I'll tell you what it did is yeah
when Baker thought like oh I've got to
spread out and there's a little hole to
throw this in to man did that hole close
quick because they're safe to say that's
not linebackers exactly right exactly
right it just makes sense I know and
there's a few creative blitzes and just
a few little you know nuanced coverages
here and there and that's all you need
I'm not saying everybody has to reinvent
the wheel but when you line up in the
same two defenses all game this day and
age you're gonna get scorched uh Josh
first thing I see in the notes talking
about Derwin James hit me man is he
incredible and he's an amazing Blitzer
man he's an amazing foot sir so we're
you were very high on Derwin James yeah
and then the draft process you cooled
off a little bit gently in pre-season
and stuff and even in like the first
game or two when people were trying to
say like oh yeah I was like I don't cuz
he would have a good pick but he'd still
get burned on some other plays he was
where is he now he would fall into the
list of like what we talked about with
the Seattle guys like where he's not
thinking anymore and now you're getting
to see the true physical ability example
you gave before it was I forgot I said
that yeah it all comes full circle
but yes he has gotten to that point
where I feel like I see his speed on the
field
like finally well be the first few weeks
I was like damn like come on take off go
get that guy or you know turn your hips
and run and go get him now he's
attacking throwing his body around more
and his ability to be slippery as a
Blitzer is like forget about moves he's
got he's got the ability to do like
defensive line hand moves to slap
tackles and and running backs hands out
of the way when they're going to pass
protect against them and he is well he I
mean remember we saw the clip of him in
college lifting a tackle from Florida
off the ground yeah password yeah and I
know they you the good thing about
Florida State I feel like when you come
out as a prospect is they make you play
everywhere remember like who are they
playing a defensive tackle
Josh sweat yeah yeah Josh sweat like
they play their ends a tackle right play
your life back for some and get our own
best 11 on the field and most impo cuz I
don't know if they're gonna do that
anymore it's like let's just get him out
there yes so durman's really blowing you
away right now as a pass rusher yes he
is he yeah he's just Joey Bosa coming I
know two things for the Chargers Joey
Bosa and they don't have Travis Benjamin
you know where is the speedster right
now so he's been hurt and I can't
remember what it is but and they're four
and two there four and two and have
truly gotten better like every week the
last good to remind people who they lost
to exactly the Rams and the Chiefs
Chiefs in week one this is I'm telling
you it's something that we need to
remember to do is we do our preseason
predictions it's good to look back and
go okay I still have a lot of faith in
this team and look they're still doing
well but Chargers lost like two national
games I've been betting against him a
lot it's a foot injury it's a foot
injury that's scary
yeah it's things what are they saying
though I'm just saying that he heard it
originally in week four and he was out
indefinitely other side of the field
though it sounds like they really just
Baker didn't have any chance to breathe
is what it's no not really they did a
good job of just harassing him they were
all over their pass game I want to say
that yeah there's a lot of plays that
happened that I know don't swing the
game but when I am betting I can get
upset right but it was 14 nothing
chargers yeah and they ran the same play
- Tyrell William Tyrell Williams the
left tackle had a clear false start
clear false start Oh was that that game
where he clears false start on the left
side there yes touchdown play on the
touchdown he clearly jumped and miles
gallery meant waited a Sunday it was
like that's a false start right and the
announcer because I'm watching the car
go coast that's a false start and then
Philip Rivers goes back and throws a
touchdown and me going I bet on the back
of the bra Browns right here I'm gonna
that's a false start and they never
called it yeah how was it going in the
car were you reacting in the car like
you do at the office there was a fight
I'm sure that was that game yes well
here's the play okay so I I feel like
this is not this play so oh you mean the
second touchdown later no the second
touchdown where they run the same play
yeah well it wait this is it isn't it
hold on watch he's gonna throw the post
over the top yeah the second one maybe
the first one alright so I'm gonna go
back to the first one because I'm gonna
call you I can't think it was the second
one that there I think I might have been
later on in the game and you're getting
the plays maybe there was another deep
touchdown it might have been but I just
say the guy was really off there
definitely was and I remember on Sunday
going damn how did they miss that that's
ridiculous but I just couldn't remember
what game it was on right now either way
that was a really cool moment to me why
cuz offensive coaches don't call the
same PI twice they're too cool for
school to do that let alone twice in a
row twice in a row like what that was
groundbreaking that's what I'm talking
about Ken Whisenhunt like don't let
teams place stupid freakin defenses
against certain formations little
estimation that dumb before it's our job
to teach them exactly right we need to
teach them that this is not sound
football and we got to teach them a
lesson so he's one of my favorite
Gruden's so let's watch it tonight
obviously how I feel about work so look
look what look what they're doing you
two nitwits here okay show it to him
it's more important okay all right oops
I just clicked oh yeah actually if you
hold it right there too they can kind of
see it with the camera
damn then Josh's camera hopefully the
NFL doesn't
I never heard of them yeah so just take
Josh's camera it's basically like a
Tampa to look right hold on it's like a
Tampa to look yeah okay
and you could see okay look how they're
doing it they got these guys these are
gonna be your corners yeah here yeah and
that guy's had to go to the safety and
that guy's had to go to the safety and
the whole middle of the fields oh but so
they do a play-action so now it took him
a little while to get down there BAM
gone all right completion very next play
not the exact same formation but pretty
much the same formation with just a
different personnel set and it's gonna
be the same exact defense and they got
the corners involved in the edge run
game right and look at the same route on
the bottom of their pits to say it's
exactly the same there's nobody to jam
either receiver so this safety is like
damn thanks Corner thanks for just
letting him run up on me I only have to
cover half the field for you now and he
has no chance and Ken was a nut I'm sure
said that on saw that on film it was
like man they're gonna keep playing this
formation I'm gonna call the place
touchdown after that or though I think
it was later on that's what I mean yeah
that was cool that was a film breakdown
that was the first time ever we've done
it on the pod Miles Garrett was awesome
he is on anything from that side of the
ball though overall that kind of stuck
out to you I mean the the Chargers the
Chargers run game is really becoming a
force you know there are another team
like we talked about the Patriots a
little and things like that on Monday
like they're they're old school run game
is tough to defend I want to talk about
that yeah Melvin Gordon Todd Gurley yeah
how close is it right now oh it's very
close I mean it's not very yeah it's
close I think Gurley is definitely the
best running back in football for me I
don't think I can deny that and I'm
really I love Melvin Gordon I'm not
gonna say he's better than say Cuong
Barkley why yeah I'm not so you
currently would go Gurley Barkley Gordon
I think so
mmm I think so yeah Gordon would be in
the conversation for me with him and
Ezekiel Elliott and I think I would go
with Gordon I think I would go Gordon
first over Ezekiel all right now
Gordon's doing I think more breaking
tackles it's incredible more in the past
game on a weekly basis it really
is incredible and you know he just he
never misses a hole he's got an
incredible vision you know he tackles
himself sometimes more than he gets
attacked well yeah yes because he just
is like he's like a kamikaze ball
sometimes or he just gets going so hard
he's run through tackles that he like
loses his feet and kind of just falls
like wrist funny cuz like we've hung out
with him like a super nice guy yeah I
know but he gets out there and he just
he's he's finally I feel like running
behind his pads and but okay so you have
Wow girly Barkley Gordon yeah yeah that
would go Zeke after that and then who's
five we pull up the teams yeah don't
count levy on cuz he hasn't played yet
nope I will not count him I promise you
that
hoo-wee mission mink I know I'll tell
you Kareem hunts in that cover oh yeah
yeah put him in there not go like that I
think it is because I think Kareem hunt
I feel line under the radar I feel like
of all the players in the NFL this
offseason he was one of the more
disrespected guys yeah where I just felt
like everyone's like oh yeah
you led the entire NFL in rushing your
rookie year right but we're not gonna
talk about you yeah right and he is
destroying people yes he's got a
deceptive speed I think he and he loves
playing I think over anybody has I think
he is the best vision of all the players
Wow
and he is the best patience to let plays
develop to where he has a great feel for
okay I'm gonna stay behind my blockers
and kind of ride the wave and I'm just
gonna sit here and wait until Lane pops
out and then BAM I bounce it out to the
left and I run for 40 yards on the left
sideline
I think Kareem hunt is the most
physically punishing of the three I
think Melvin Gordon whenever i watch to
run I go uh-uh uh-uh like he just he
slowly breaks down every lever and he
escapes and he jumps over a guy and
girly I just sit and go yeah girl he's
like we're about just like essence yeah
he doesn't break stride he Beach it to
the edge he turns up feeling right and
then say Kwan I go
no no no no at least I did on Thursday
holy crap yeah sake was special you know
again don't I don't care what his stats
are where his rushing for the season is
it's a team sport and even if your super
man likes a qualm Barkley you need holes
and a little help every now and then
let's go to the other beatdown Ravens
Titans right Ravens
facing Mariota how the hell did they get
11 SEC's
flipping through my pages first of all
we've informed everybody over the last
few weeks that the interior offensive on
the Tennessee Titans is not good okay
and the Baltimore Ravens have waves of
players that they can send at you that
are just big mofos I don't know what
other way to say it they got just if you
listed the team is who's got the biggest
mofos in the world on their team you'd
go Baltimore Ravens they win and their
defensive line just has so many big
physical specimens that could ruin our
93 96 98 in your this is one of the
biggest ass weapons of the year it is
and it was just like it wasn't like
Seattle was a little bit more like we're
getting on the edge and we're shooting
through the gap and you guys can't even
like slow us down this was just like
yeah this was just like I got you Brett
Jones and I'm gonna push you back in
tamari on his face and he was just like
oh I can't stop you is there anything
that other teams can replicate because
you wrote mariota's worst nightmare
keep him in the pocket yeah and give him
nothing over the middle yeah so was that
is that the formula I mean I think
that's a big part of Mario to his game
is he's not a great outside the numbers
thrower he's not the kind of guy that's
gonna beat you with comebacks and out
routes and fade stops all game long
right whether you even go back to the
organ days that's what we've always seen
him do yeah you know pi action pass pull
it really good quick release hit the
slant over the middle or the little pop
pass we talked about her maybe the post
or the cross over the top that's really
more his game and then if he doesn't
feel
they're Bowl he gets out of the pocket
cuz he has great speed and then he makes
the defense commit and he can either run
or if they commit to aggressively he
finds an open receiver behind them but
yeah they were cognizant of that and
always had the Jew dons or the shrugs
out there wide-area Smythe's so where
this Darius Smith is right who could
missus who could stay out there and just
at least make it hard for him to run
around the edge if not be able to let
him run around it at all so is the
Titans and tear offensive line really
bad or is it just because they're facing
Jacksonville Philadelphia Baltimore
Houston and like successively yeah that
that's part of it is they're facing
amazing defensive line it's in a
below-average interior offensive line I
don't think you can deny that you're you
were this just in Titans interior line
is bad it's bad and they really were
whooped in all facets of the game
offensively for the Ravens you really
liked the Lamar Jackson Wildcat I did
like it and they didn't they only did it
I believe one time and again got to the
edge it got down to the two or three you
know I'm very underwhelmed by their
running backs IRA not a big Alex Collins
fan you're not a big buck Allen fan I
really think that they would be like the
most dangerous team in the football if
they had a really legit running back
because there's holes and more yards to
be had than they get now they're good
and they run hard where Jackson that guy
got swear I think I was trying to go
with that comment like don't forget
about this part of your offense this is
a nice little thing to have into the
game plan on a weekly basis they have
this big powerful offensive line and he
is a change of pace and when he came in
the game in the third quarter after
they'd been running the ball a lot with
the other two guys and then all sudden
he ran and went damn
he looked fast to me he looked faster
than those two running backs I know that
and I just think it's something that
they have to continue to do they really
do it's it's it has their offenses not
that complicated like we've talked about
it's better than years past but that's a
nice little element to make teams have
to defend on a weekly basis maybe
they're waiting to their schedule gets
tougher to maybe they break out more
maybe I am I am very happy that the
Ravens played as well as they did the
week before they played the Saints yeah
we're gonna call your dad and to
it's Flacco was amazing really well you
can't you can't Flacco the Ravens the
Titans did a pretty good job they didn't
let any easy completions like it was
nothing easy it was Joe Flacco throwing
20-yard piss missiles on the sideline
it was like Joe Flacco yeah the road
yeah and I mean he just was he made a
lot of big-time throws where Malcolm
Butler was in good coverage and the
perfect throw was made and they picked
on Malcolm Butler I was gonna say as
someone who's been a very staunch
supporter welcome Butler where is he
right now he's still got good cover
abilities definitely not a top-10 corner
he is his biggest issue this whole year
has been playing the football I mean
just think about week one in Miami
remember we had the Kenny Stills bomb
post it was up he was there he raked at
the guys arm as he was about to catch a
grab tree got a touchdown on him on site
exactly right it was a back shoulder
fade right and yeah it was way out of
this that's where it's just like not
it's not he hasn't been as good this
year where in yours past I feel like
he's been all over those guys he's been
able to pry the ball loose or knock it
down and yeah this year it's it's been a
completion more times than not Ravens go
Saints at Carolina home against
Pittsburgh by home against Cincinnati
man that's some that's a physical toll
right there dude I'm just looking though
like that then it fells so evenly
matched right now yeah every game looks
tie now all right so we're calling big
film or sale for your dad I think we
should call home try to home Nicky I
wonder like you missed a few things in
the Packers game but just thought you
know you didn't read my Packers notes
very good very well we looked at them
together did you yeah
well one thing you got better well we're
calling a Phil you wrote down that Chris
Jones is a leader in the Kansas City New
England game what did you mean by that
because you want to talk about who's the
biggest cheerleader on the sideline
during that game you could see him every
time the offense made a big play he was
yeah let's go did you hear what they
said to him at half five Kareem hunt yes
she already said they said it better
than half-time Michele Tafoya said they
were running into the tunnel okay
and Chris Jones is going we got this
we're okay come on by Holmes we're not
out of this like that's some fun
your [ __ ] mississippi state crap I like
that I do too yeah a lot of crap - yeah
we know crap I tell you we're talking
though turnout but soon - listen we're
talking about crap oh my god well we're
talking about Chris Jones being a leader
and Simms was upset or Chris was upset
that I wasn't looking at his Packers
Niners I think he kind of breezed
through my notes this week what did I
miss
look at your notes could you breathe
through the notes first off how do you
read them they're so damn small you
didn't need a magnifying glass to read
them so I don't Josh was watching me
read them today I could read them quick
I had I had no idea what I was looking
at you right I have learned so that
whatever that's called Scripture yeah or
whatever something my work suffers Jones
he was leading the team a little what's
wrong with that you know I you know yeah
I'm and I know you're the same way dad
like as I'm watching a film you know you
look at the sidelines every now and then
to see the reaction of certain plays and
things like that and you know Chris
Jones is very much like a like this
story you've told about Fletcher Cox
when Carson Wentz started to take over
right he was going man Carson Wentz out
there I'm gonna stand up and watch this
and Chris Jones I feel like does the
same exact thing but the Kansas City
Chiefs he's like damn I sat there and
watch this offense and he stands up and
cheers for them harder than anybody else
in the sideline you know in the
highlights we show on Showtime which I
think are great they are publicity there
but the great but it does a lot of times
it's really cool we probably should
point it out more but sometimes we don't
get to see the the highlights until they
put the show together you know the NFL
Films it's not ready but whatever it's
really cool when the defensive players
are standing up on the sidelines rooting
and going come on man you can do it and
you know just to see their emotions and
all that because it's it's awesome it
really is didn't used to make you feel
good when like dad for a long time till
the Lawrence Taylor well or ins would
always congrats to me after touchdown
right right yeah yeah okay and you then
maybe you know what I'm more curious to
keep right I do have a picture of him
and I 1993 when we beat Chicago right to
a touchdown I don't know with a few
seconds ago and
first one there was Lawrence it's a
really good shot because we're ACOG oh
it's grass yeah dirty the whole thing
and you know it is good shine then he
got a sack fumble to close the game out
to you to all the timers contribute to
that Dame is a Bears coach right oh no
I'm sorry not as first it would have
been a second year would have been is
first that was our first game at 93 yeah
that was opening game so his first day
yeah I'm glad we did a good job of
ruined his day there we go Phil did you
hear what Bill Belichick said about
Lawrence Taylor today I did and what do
you think I think he'd be right hmm
absolutely
did you know Khalil max had you know
really good player is he going to be
ever be Lawrence Taylor no it's a
different style for one you know Khalil
Marcus probably maybe a little more of a
power player but I even have a hard time
saying that because what about like us
bond Miller well you know Lawrence it
just was such a big guy Lawrence is
bigger than bond really people
understand he's broad-shouldered long
armed and just he's just big and it
hidden because he trained these other
guys trained to get big
I mean Lawrence did he did the reverse
training method see he might have had
that maybe that's the key you guys did
the reverse training method because
Simms there's only one thing to do just
gotta go crazy okay go for it big guy
but uh but I heard Belichick and I could
have told you when questions come up
about that football team on defense
he very seldom is gonna give anybody
platitudes they're gonna reach higher
than what he believed in 86 defense
because my first thought is okay you
guys are all biased because I do you
experienced some success you want a
championship there's you know LT and it
was a special time for you guys Bill
Belichick's young you're a young
whippersnapper and I think that you're
all biased and that you don't want to
give the younger generations credit
because a bigger and stronger offensive
in Yin please you know I
Kristopher slap him come on I will when
I give any good cause that died in the
face just hit him in the back of my head
so that
from these turtle cause who know we can
remember I make him listen at them here
you go you're making such a compelling
argument then and you guys are just this
and that is just total 100 what we start
this conversation out with crap yeah
right and you know it listen I'm not
being you're telling me it's 20 to 30
years later that with the way that
humans have evolved playing professional
athlete and the training dominate the
NFL yeah but like don't you think that
if Von Miller went back then he would
dominate just like LT did no I don't
think so either dad I'm with you I don't
think so you didn't have this edge all
the time and it was a different song now
he's going to like AAU basketball
friendly anybody's becoming he's
becoming a shock job now no matter what
I tell you you're not you you got your
side so it's fine you stay with it and
go ahead as they always see a need to be
on the right side of the wrong side
brother so you just you just choose the
wrong one that's okay so he was really
that great George listen he changed the
game he was the most nimble limber
outside rusher I have ever seen
you got that ever name me one that week
when I say he could run full-speed with
his fingertips dragging the ground on
his inside hand and turn a corner
there's a thousand shots of him seeing
it during games and all the NFL
highlights you see and that's what made
him different that he could do stuff
like that and maybe the fact that he
didn't lips kept him limber
so who knows but listen
competitive and really good at
everything like I've told you before he
could shoot baskets he could really play
picked up golf you know became basically
a scratch golfer you saw him run you saw
him run four or five on grass right
Ricky here a 250 about 20 people timing
and he ran like four or five one or
something he was like are you wait wait
you guys there's something wrong
I was like well he should be like four
four four you know and this is this is
like the first day of the offseason
program it's not like we'd been there
training that's funny so God knows who's
what he was doing before then but he ran
the fastest time on the team and another
guy actually say it ran the same time
which was Byron Hunt
yeah backup linebacker so those two ran
the fastest time that day faster on
grass which it was slow the the field
outside of giant Stadium then they were
the tooth they beat all the wide
receivers in the timing so Chris you are
younger than your father
yeah obviously but your father is
tweeting up a storm and you don't even
understand how it works he is on there
tweeting given hot takes here's a good
one Sims Chris yes NFL he tweeted this
yesterday at 9:42 what are you doing
Phil in the morning or at night yes I
say today I tweet at night NFL should
put a team in London and first of all
before Phil explains Chris thoughts on
your dad saying the NFL should expand in
London well I mean my thoughts on him
tweeting at 9:42 at night are impressive
that's the first thing I um yeah I don't
know somehow see how you could work in
London I guess that's my my big issue
you know and not that I don't want to
see the NFL expand but yeah I guess
there's a part of me that doesn't want
to see it expand I guess a little bit I
don't want another team I know that I
don't know I want number team 33 and
team 34 okay that I know I don't want I
think the NFL was best when it was at 28
and the teams are more condensed with
really awesome football players and
maybe a little spread thin now at 32 but
I would just say today I don't know how
it works as far as salary cap all that
stuff travel that would be my only so
what inspired you to tweet that last
night felt because I said it on TV
why'd you say it on TV because I believe
it and I do believe that listen I don't
believe it I know the NFL wants to go to
Europe my god I did those games over
there so many times and I went to the
Embassy of the United States over there
and we had big cocktail parties and this
and that we'd have to go in like oh my
god but everybody in there was some
from France Germany here United States
there and they all were saying the same
thing we can't wait till we get a team
over here and would it work oh my god
it'll work you know I met the guy over
there that sells NFL merchandise somehow
the NFL owner sold it to this one person
I said how business and he almost
laughed he was like cry it's cause it's
because I can't keep things in the store
and when you walk around over there the
day of the games in London you literally
see a jersey from every team and it you
know it's amazing now of course the
Patriots are there they did it a few
times and they tried to kind of gather
that part of the world I guess you would
say yeah I did see more New England
Patriots than any other team but you see
them all Tennessee Titans I just go wow
how could this guy yeah but what made
you tweet this last night what made you
say it yesterday well I said it
yesterday cuz we were going I don't know
what we were going through maybe it was
something about that I can't remember
the question you know I talked so much
Adam I can't remember everything but we
did it on show time so you hey listen I
watch your show every Wednesday night I
put you know go through that so yeah she
watched my show time show he's selfish
daddy's a selfish millennial that's all
we could say not what it is I I'm not a
bird tweeting comes from if I stayed on
TV I'm gonna tweet it they are trying to
if I just got degree philosophy he's a
multi-platform brand he's on TV he's on
Twitter we got to get you an Instagram
fill we're just got to get him here in
the office you know Instagram is I'm
just not crazy about taking pictures I
think I hear ya Thank You ina hurt you
know Instagram then yeah yeah so I had I
had my assistant take some pictures of
me yesterday when the show was over cuz
I want to use them and I looked at it
and I went man every one of them made
that stupid face I got like that crooked
smile I go okay so that was a waste of
time
well Phil we appreciate your time but
when you when you home tonight I think
the app you need to download is snack
--all it's this new thing that all the
kids are using I think you'd really like
snack oh no well give me a real quick
rundown water today
it's about snackable content so it's
short quick videos so it's like if you
have something you're watching film you
have a quick take you go on snack
and you put it on there and the kids
snack he dad he's being a total [ __ ]
right now he's totally making [ __ ] up
and I just threw the microphone at me
yeah I'm not gonna let you do I'm not
gonna let him do that to you he's such a
jerk
I'm legitimately gonna hit him for you
and we're done this show going on but
you know I'm gonna tell you what now
I've had a lot of friends in my life I
said to hell with them and I left them
that I haven't talked to them in 20
years they're gone so you do this trying
to work your hands that way well you
should reconnect with them no I held on
to them way too long anyway so you know
they were jerks and I don't know why I
was there whatever you know anything
else you two idiots got well show gonna
be tonight I think it'll be pretty good
it'll be good we had best football
friends against Avery Williamson and
Darren Lee we had a little untold story
from tio and your son explained wwbd
what would Belichick do yeah and his his
big take is that maybe as the whole NFL
is going to spread offenses maybe bill
is bringing back a power running game
well they never get away from the run
game use it unless they have one of
those really crazy game plans which I
honestly I thought they were going to
come out and probably throw it the first
25 plays against Kansas City yeah me too
so I hate that one and but then as you
watch it and everything I just I had
that argument on Showtime if you watch
the show that's right mr. selfish but I
watch all as everything i watch some of
your when y'all picking games you're
looking at Christopher's notes I'm going
oh my god
but what the hell are we talking about
you know the Patriots in the run game oh
yeah yeah watching the game and then I
was shocked when I watched the video of
it I was like God Almighty i watch the
game live on TV I don't remember him
getting the i-formation
I said the same thing there was such a
thing at him you don't want Christopher
yeah that's why they ran the ball so
well because Kansas City goes what the
hell is that over there
I know it's unreal nobody knows that a
defendant real it was on it and what did
I tell you about the Patriots what a
roster oh the three guys that will make
the team always yeah go okay I got three
spots covered the rest of you're
fighting for a job and who are the three
that are guaranteed Tom Brady right the
full-back Devlin Devlin and Slater on
special teams that's it the rest of you
you're in the middle of it
have a nice fight he's right yeah yeah
yeah I know that was I said that to me
last night on the phone and that was
pretty spot-on
you know he was already in a state of I
gotta go pass out I don't know what it
was call that we call that backboard
season and you know I will say this my
son I know you Adam I'm sure you don't
watch this radio show in the morning
because you're too busy looking at
yourself in the mirror but today was
really good Christopher I really it was
the best one of the best football shows
I think I've ever watched I kid you not
wow thank you that it thanks dad I
appreciate that man what are you saying
you know one of our competitors our
competitor are they really because they
do night football right Fox will be our
competitor right and I don't care who is
you know whatever but it was a very good
show so I want to say that thanks dad I
appreciate that man see I could give out
a compliment every once a while and you
know to the guy you're working with yeah
yeah see you guys all right a man that's
gonna grind your gears what it was fine
because he bought smackle I mean
couldn't you see I like it we just got
done with it today we didn't have to say
my dog he was like I'm out of here
that's it you really didn't read my
green bay notes very well he really did
you didn't even say anything about you
know the player juice juice EJ I call
him yeah you snooze check yeah I can
never do we called him Juicy J this
young apartment doesn't work I'll play
call I've never seen it ever in the NFL
you didn't even say it I mean he ran the
full-back out of the weak side of the
formation and the guy ran a deep cross
like an was wide open of course because
he was in the I formation and dad is
right about that like I'm
that's why bill is going back to this
because linebackers are going are played
in the big 12 and they've never run in
the I formation ever so I'm used to
going to tackle wide receiver screen
wide receiver screen quick slant and I
got to watch the quarterback scramble
and now linebackers and defensive tackle
is this day and age like damn they're
running downhill and the full-backs
about to hit me and there's a guard
pulling I've never seen this before
that's truly where we're at in football
because high schools become spread for
the most part yeah but yeah this theory
it's a great theory but Kyle we've seen
him before he like Bluffs the blocker
and he took it to another level so he
play-action to the left with the
tailback the fullback came out the
backside gap between I think the garden
tackle and ran a deep cross to his left
though that play is usually you know
tight under your right
okay the X receiver on your left runs
two posts to clear it out and now you
have the deep cross and the outside
receiver runs it in cut so you can just
go post deep cross let me look to the
income from right here progression
really exactly right and he did it with
the full-back and I just say that
fullback did the deep cross instead of
the tight exactly and it's just like the
linebacker saw him run by it was like I
don't know where he's going but I better
go run and chase him and did bend it and
hit the past yeah they hit it members
check fumble you know people are oh yeah
forget the 49ers fumble to kick return
and that play would have been a bad I
know I was sitting there going man my
bet is gonna get screwed here I mean I
was really like I can't believe this is
happening to me man all right I got some
fan stuff for you okay all right
Garrett's with an interesting
proposition did he go with the rest of
the team notes you're not even talking
about the Chiefs Pat's game to be
talking about that whole game we spent
35 minutes on Monday and the only part
that we didn't talk about was Chris
Jones as a great leader everything else
we talked about at length that's how
good you are watching football on TV he
had it all pal okay all right I'll
believe you me and Josh literally talked
you've had a 35 minute breakdown of the
game on Monday okay good all right good
right Garrett says what if at the end of
the season the Raiders decide car isn't
worth the money and they try and trade
him to the
Giants who said this right Gerrits of
white that's how viable this this
possibly is that you were like wow did
someone ever know do you think car would
fit the Schirmer offense well I do I do
think he would fit the offense well what
do you think about Derek Carr maybe the
Giants cuz it me no you don't think
we're gonna give up on it I don't think
you will yet I bet my biggest reason for
that is because of their offensive
coordinators Greg Olson and Greg Olson
was there when they drafted Derek Carr
and I know he thinks very highly of him
and I just think they will not give up
on that quite yet I don't think so nor
am i sure if Derek cars New York City
material I just say that I mean I don't
mean that in a disrespectful way not
everybody is not everybody can handle
you know like what the [ __ ] you talking
abou to and like doing all that all the
time and being under that microchip so
funny like these athletes live in the
middle of nowhere New Jersey when they
live in you yeah I know
like they react like they walk down
Broadway and have to deal with like
pedaling angry fans right but usually
live in like a neighborhood in like a
complex you having a bonfire in his
backyard on a Tuesday but the media
following is still greater and if you
went in the locker room on a Wednesday
in New York Giants it would be a lot
more packed media members than it would
be if you went out to the Denver Broncos
on a Wednesday no Giants start off one
in five and it's the front page of every
newspaper like the the Niners start off
what if I think we'll figure it out yeah
Alan three nine five six eight four
three nine people were very upset at the
list you put on pro football talk of
your top ten receivers in which you had
Tyree kill number one right but what a
lot of people are upset about as a guy
that's not on the list what Michael
Thomas yes
dude you are in New Orleans hater how
can Michael Thomas not be on the top ten
list are you high or just completely
clueless low little josh Josh McNulty
comes and says for you not to have
Michael Thomas on this list makes the
list of relevant Brandon cooks yeah both
Belichick and Peyton got rid of him but
what are they
No okay and what does McVeigh know is he
not the offensive genius of football and
wanted them oh okay all right all right
but like Michael Thomas not the top okay
it's a tough thing to make a list Josh
who else is on the list so the list is
one Tyree kill two Julio Jones three
Odell Beckham for Antonio Brown v aj
green 60 Andre Hopkins 7 Mike Evans 8
Adam Thielen 9 juju 10 Brandon cooks I'm
sorry we just got a top five running
back ranking out of you didn't even know
it no I just quietly yeah okay it's hard
to make these lists okay so he's
competing you had juju at nine and cooks
at ten yeah so that's who he's competing
with pretty much exactly right eight was
Mike Evans yeah it was Mike Evans man I
know that you believe that Mike Evans
can do more on an island than Michael
Thomas can yes
but it's really I think the juju Brandon
cooks you think that's the one that
bothers people well I think because like
I think that a lot of people go okay I
could see you put in feeling over him
right now right I could see you putting
DeAndre Hopkins I think that you have AJ
green in a place that some people
sometimes pick him lower but look when
AG greens on he's incredible yes I think
that the debate comes in the nine and
ten spots right which is Brandon cooks
and juju okay so like all right first of
all everybody's a moment of the stats
guy right man that's that's really what
it all comes down to look at their
fantasy teams and you just Smith's stats
for one are better than Michael Thomas's
okay so let me just start there I like
Michael Thomas again these are not
indictments on pyres like Michael's the
11th best wide receiver
I mean he's yes he's right there in that
conversation like he certainly is
realized that in the fantasy community
which i think is the simple way of
judging where guys are ranked right
Michaels Thomas was if you're in a 12
team draft typically going 14th or 15
right right around the Keenan Allen's
the Davante Adams ahead of Mike Evans
that just made my point that just made
my point
the Keenan Allen's and who is the other
one you said too
hey Adams right right ahead of my Kevin
right ahead of Juji okay those three
though are ahead of all those guys none
of them are those players none of them
are as good I don't care just because
their stats are better doesn't mean
they're better players yeah the only
receivers going a happening really
devout like come on that's ridiculous
was the other name you said Davante
Adams Ian Allen Keenan Allen come on
like really keen talents he's a real
good receiver nobody's going like oh man
if we don't put our best corner on
Keenan Ellen we're gonna lose the game
against the Chargers you know I base a
lot and Michael Thomas is awesome again
I'm trying to say that to people but see
their take with those three guys an
example you know you're taking their
offense or the situation like yeah
Davante Adams is Aaron Rodgers go-to guy
he can be covered like glue and Aaron
Rodgers throws it in this pocket and
gets interception and we go well his
stat his fantasy is off - off the wall
except yeah he caught a ball in the back
end zone that like only four people in
the history of football could have
thrown sidearm fadeaway 40 yard throw
into the back left corner of the endzone
for inches above a cornerback who's got
a 35 inch vertical and raised his arms
up and if he didn't throw it exactly
there the ball goes out of bounds or it
gets picked off but we're gonna go we're
gonna give Davante Adams all the credit
it was a nice catch I get that but I
think that's what we have to take into
context like Michael Thomas's I'd love
him to be on my offense but I just
wouldn't pick him ahead of these other
guys so you would take juju over Michael
time I would because I think juju is
capable of doing more after the catch
and now I think that's very important to
me
and Juju's catch on Sunday was insane
he's a very similar player to Michael
Thomas except he's capable of doing more
after the catch that's really where I
separate it you know what is it that you
do after like a lot of guys can be wide
open over the middle and catch a ball
you know the Saints offense is awesome I
know that I'm not a saint ater I picked
them to go to the Super Bowl and I want
to be right I'm rooting for the Saints I
love Sean Peyton I really like Drew
Brees I don't know what else to say I
love their style of football I'm just
trying to have an honest conversation to
tell people that Michael Thomas is very
good but he would be another guy again
that I would tell you the one defenses
are playing Michael Thomas they
might go we have to slow Michael Thomas
down but it's not because they're scared
of his physical ability they're going
because Sean Payton makes them such a
focal point and create so many things
for him within the offense to get
completions diggs or Michael Thomas I
would go Michael Thomas there Robert
Woods and were Michael Thomas I would go
Michael Thomas and all of them have
better stats than my Robert was at
you're better than Michael Thomas right
Robert Woods is well he's got he's got
ten less catches but he's got five more
yards okay Michael Thomas is catching
eleven point three yards per catch
that's not even in the stratosphere of
all these guys were talking about hotels
eleven point yeah okay but we know why
yeah so wait so are we gonna say Odell's
not a top I walked right into that well
yeah because you're right because like
again we have to take it all don't
everybody be prisoners Tyler Boyd or
Michael Thomas I'm taking Michael Thomas
I have great so Zach Ertz or Michael Tom
I'm taking Michael Tom how do you [ __ ]
that way but yes he's really good but
I'm just saying like teams are not going
man if we don't if Michael Thomas is
lined up outside if we don't double
cover him or do that then we're in deep
trouble it's just not that kind of thing
and again I have a great respect for him
but I do put like fact like some some
analysis into okay when he catches a
10-yard ball over the middle what does
he do with it afterwards and I would say
you know it's gonna be hard to come up
with a whole lot of highlight plays of
Michael Thomas getting incredibly yack
plays after the fact other than the ones
where he catches like a wide open deep
cross and then gets to turn it upfield
seamlessly and nobody's around him and
again I'm not trying to downplay him I
know he's really good so I mean that
that's basically my basis people have
pushed very hard back against my Tyreke
kill thing I'm sure I didn't even
whatever I don't know people keep coming
to me with the weapon he's just a weapon
isn't that what a frickin receiver is I
don't know when did Randy Moss become
the greatest route runner in the history
of the sport
Randy Ross is Randy Moss was an average
route runner average but he could fly
and he could jump and when he caught a 5
yard pass he said
oh gosh he might run by all of us 480
yards in a touchdown
there's significance to that Tyree
killed when he catches a slam he doesn't
get tackled at the 5 he scores a
touchdown Julio Jones hasn't scored a
touchdown this year and they might not
get in the endzone and then they kick a
field goal and I go man those four
points were pretty big but Tyreke got in
Tyreke is the best weapon whatever you
want to say he is I'm just saying he's
the most dangerous receiver in football
and that equates to the best receiver in
football you it as an ex quarterback
have you said you could have one guy to
run a go route I'd go
I'll take Tyree kill you can have one
guy to throw a slant route to I'd go i
take Tyree kill I could have one guy to
do that little invoke forward shovel
pass where everybody is the speed
sweeping you do that and you go who's
gonna do the most with it after diary
kill who could you put a putt reciept
punt returner in the NFL right now
they're all the receivers and who would
you be scared of the most
Tyree kill so why doesn't that get
included when we talk about Deion
Sanders being one of the greatest
corners of all time we also talked about
yo names amazing returner too so he's a
great weapon and he causes so much
stress on a defense that was on my only
point and you don't have to agree these
number one I'm just saying for people
not to at least put him in the
conversation for that that is ridiculous
at this point there's no there's no
denying it he is he is fourth in the NFL
and receiving yards out of all these big
names that we talked about on this list
he has better yards for catch than all
of them and he's tied for first with
touchdowns so what do you think it'll s
yeah like I guess serious I was really
good I think you forgot Crabtree but no
but anybody else on the list or you
think like I really struggled with
hopkins and aj green of a horror I
should put in front of each other there
you know I have Hopkins over AG would go
hop it was very tough I actually wrote
Hopkins down first and then I was like
oh I think I'm gonna switch him when I'm
AJ Green there I said this to you before
the podcast yeah but you had a lot of
people in our youtube comments that came
to your defense and yeah brought up the
same thing that you said about being a
dangerous play yeah any why isn't he's
not the greatest route runner in the
world I understand that there's things
that other guys do better than him well
I was gonna say this is we like visual
similarity
we like certain positions to look a
certain way you're right that's part of
it and Tyriq is I mean his first year he
was a running back yeah like he was a
running back like I caught him on my
fantasy team as a running back right so
510 185 yeah and he might be five nine
yeah he might be but he doesn't you know
Michael Thomas looks like Keyshawn
Johnson right is his cousin or uncle
yeah like yeah he looks like the
prototypical number one like Stefon
Diggs looks like a beautiful wide
receiver ight but here comes Tyree kill
and you go you go but he's not as tall
but my question is why are we why have
we overlooked it with Antonio Brown and
we've accepted him as a wide receiver
but I know it's just that's why that's
why I came up with this conversation we
got to break ourselves out of these
norms sometimes of like this like
there's just it's just hey just look at
the field everybody trusts your eyes
don't go on fantasy like come on there's
nobody that could really do what he did
in that last touchdown of the game last
week super Happy's on our fantasy to
jump up in the air contort stop and a
dead stop the Safety's there to make the
tackle he restarts and he goes around
like like nobody like that's that's all
I was trying to say and I don't say
everybody has to be one and I know the
Michael Thomas thing was very hard it
really was I was sad there and I was
like man because I was sitting here
looking at stats and I'm going through
teams and I'm going man I says doing the
list I go man people are gonna crap all
over me about Michael Thomas you could
easily knocked off Brandon cooks and
nobody would sit in yeah yeah yeah you
think so I know but Brandon cooks is a
phenomenal route runner he's a little
bit more of a deep threat than Michael
Thomas let's see that's why I appreciate
you and that's why I hope the Sims and
Lefko fans appreciate you and the
hustlers Thanks because I stress about
it I knew I had to make this list last
night it was on my shoulders all night
and I got home and I was like I mean I
played ball tag with the kids you know
ball tag you've talked to the great game
so I played that I helped them with
homework and then the whole time I'm
going man I got to make this list I got
to make this list and I was stressing
about I'm doing it my head I'm thinking
about it and then I sit down and I pull
up all my information
I fell Jesus and I look through things
and I go okay let's start writing some
names down here and try to figure this
out
and I just throw Tyriq at one and I said
damn I really want to put O'Dell too but
I don't think I can say he's number two
right now I think I got to go with Julio
and then I said okay Odell's three it's
really close between him and Antonio
Brown right now but I'm gonna give it a
todo I know his stats weren't in there
their stratosphere or up the same but
come on we've talked about it for five
weeks in a row that he's been wide open
a number of times yeah he doesn't have a
quarterback to throw zone I'm just
waiting for the Odell slant that he
turns the corner and runs yes he's doing
a little LeSean McCoy right now we're
like Enda Shawn Jackson sometimes where
he catches it and then he turns and he
goes who am I gonna do yeah and it's
like O'Dell just keep going yeah like
he'd he like holds the ball out and he's
like I'm gonna Juke and it's like you're
letting everyone catch you yeah I'm just
waiting for the ODE the track meet Odell
I know and I don't think he's totally
there yet - I have been trying to say
that to people I don't think he has his
total sixth gear yet I think he only has
five and a half right now like like you
talked about what was that I listed
Alvin Kamara as a wide receiver and we
were only doing just weapons would he be
above a lot of those guys weapons list
could be a different list and you just
gave us an idea for next week coming up
on the Wednesday podcast next week we
almost Sims the left coast show next
week all right what else any other
pushback from you guys on the receivers
things I hope that was a productive
conversation I don't want to sound angry
or anything no cuz look we all we all
understand what you're saying and I
think that some people value things
differently and we learned this about
the quarterback position every year in
the NFL Draft right and people feel like
you encouraged arm strength too much
right and we go yeah cuz it's arm
strength yeah with Tyree kill you go
yeah I people that break tackles and are
faster than people and can make big
plays that's right just look at history
those are the players that are the best
value consistency yes they love Hines
Ward's 144 catches more than they love
Randy Moss is 20-something touchdown
you're right but what's the point I know
I don't you would rather a guy have 12
catches for 90 and a guy
three catches for 163 and I guitar yeah
and which I would go but he was
insistent I go yeah but what's the point
yeah but the three big you want to win
time of possession and win first downs
or do you want to score more pull right
right and they gotta remember two of
them I can I don't argue with with fools
because from the distance people can't
tell who's who
and that's how you full circle the jay-z
quote from earlier and that's what we're
gonna rap so don't say anything is it's
only gonna make it work for six out only
for the LEF koe man holla at you later
please go and check out the YouTube show
with the Jets and all those guys it is a
new episode there's a lot of fun and we
will be back pickin games tomorrow we're
Sims for the first time in weeks
made money god bless Kyle Shanahan see
you guys